i think what they want with sean is like
to him to fight a name but dominic cruz
would be great i mean pick anybody in
the [ __ ] two through [ __ ] 11. i
agree two through 12. i know
but but some had to go on again i don't
know if the mk ultra experiment
but dana woke up on the wrong side of
bed anyway
oh you know what today is
and hunter campbell's like wow he's out
it's [ __ ] wednesday
[Laughter]
and it was [ __ ] wednesday yeah [ __ ]
them all right here's what we're gonna
do hamzat and hunter has he goes you
have your notepad out yeah yeah what do
you got hanzo nate diaz september and
he's like what he's like that's right
speaking of [ __ ] wednesday that sugar
shawn always yapping about fights let's
give them peter young let's get pranking
and then hunter goes gilbert hunter goes
hunter goes hold on hold on the number
one guy in the world he goes yeah
welcome to [ __ ] wednesday
and then i think hunter goes yeah that's
[ __ ] him up real quick though just
spitballing ideas here just want to go
over everything um what if both guys win
and then what if leon edwards beats
uspin and then what if
[ __ ] pierra beats izzy dude you know
so it's like
but for the ufc they want sugar to win
do you just have to hope that patty who
fights this weekend who's gonna win i
think in the first round you hope that
in the i [ __ ] i want to protect patty
at all costs you got to hope that
[ __ ] wednesday doesn't leave leak
over in a [ __ ] wednesday next week
and then they announce paddy versus you
know [ __ ] maca chef or some [ __ ] i
don't know what they're gonna do
everybody needs to have their head on
swivel because dana woke up with [ __ ]
wednesday just decided and he just blown
up the company and you know what yeah
daddy's here for it
[Music]
my